На восьмому році війни на Сході України в Євросоюзі розглядають можливість заснувати "Військово-консультативну і тренувальну місію в Україні".
У робочих документах ЄС відзначено, що створення військово-тренувальної місії символізувало б солідарність Європи з Україною
з огляду на військову агресію Росії.
Відповідні перемовини вже ведуться, підтвердили в українському МЗС.
Очікується, що близько 60 експертів допомагатимуть Департаменту освіти Міністерства оборони України та Генштабу реформувати військову освіту.
Експерт із питань безпекової та зовнішньої політики Олександр Хара вважає, що така місія буде стратегічно корисною для України.
Реформувати військову освіту означає дбати про майбутнє армії.
А також наближувати Збройні Сили до західних стандартів ще на початковому етапі - навчальному.
Бо виходить так, що ми фактично продовжуємо готувати  фахівців за старими лекалами, пострадянськими.
А потім великі зусилля докладають наші західні партнери для того, щоб тренувати і доводити те,
що ми називаємо НАТОвськими стандартами або західними.
Адже, на відміну від Євросоюзу, допомога якого досі обмежувалася двома цивільними місіями,
Великобританія, США та Канада майже від самого початку війни на сході України надають суттєву військову допомогу.
Країни НАТО регулярно проводять навчання разом з українськими військовими.
Так, лише у рамках британської місії Orbital за період з 2015 по 2021 рік понад 20 тисяч українських військових пройшли курси за стандартами НАТО.
Тарас Чмут воював у морській піхоті і сам проходив навчання від західних партнерів.
Нині він очолює фонд "Повернись живим", який допомагає військовим з технікою, а також організовує тренінги і навчання для бійців.
Ветеран переконаний, що навчання і місії західних партнерів відіграли одну з ключових ролей у підготовці українських військових.
Можу порівняти з тим, як вчили в збройних силах в 2015-2016 роках,
порівняти з тим досвідом, який давали іноземні інструктори, зовсім інший рівень якості, системності, якого в нас немає.
І якщо його накладати на той практичний досвід бойових дій, який ми здобуваємо на Сході,
то ми отримаємо дуже потужну й унікальну синергію знань і практики, яка допомагає ефективно воювати.
Щоправда, тренери з Євросоюзу не будуть проводити навчання безпосередньо для солдатів ЗСУ.
Натомість, якщо місія буде ухвалена, вони готуватимуть викладачів українських військових університетів, академій та інститутів.
Ідея полягає в тому, щоб сформувати нову сучасну культуру в українських військах і зробити реформи у них невідворотними.
У будь-якому разі значення військово-консультативної місії ЄС не варто недооцінювати.
Тарас Чмут вважає, що місія ЄС дозволить показати деяким країнам-членам європейської спільноти, що насправді відбувається на сході України.
Навіть невелика місія буде хорошою точкою входу Євросоюзу в Україну, припускає експерт.
Впровадження подібної місії - це така точка входу ЄС в Україну, у тому числі тих країн, які скептичні до нас.
Щоб вони по-іншому починали сприймати цей весь конфлікт, розуміли, хто на кого напав,
розуміли, чиї війська, регулярні збройні сили знаходяться на частині територій Луганської і Донецької областей.
Хоча на створенні військової місії ЄС в Україні, за даними німецьких ЗМІ, особливо наполягають Естонія, Литва, Латвія, Польща, Румунія і Словаччина,
а прихильно ставляться до ідеї Швеція і Франція, одностайної підтримки наразі немає.
А рішення про такі місії зазвичай приймають консенсусом.
Оглядачі не виключають, що деякі європейські країни з острогою ставляться до створення окремої місії, бо не хочуть зайвий раз дратувати Росію.
Щоправда, за інформацією DW, під час дискусій всередині ЄС питання ставлення Росії не порушується.
Слід, до речі, зауважити, що про місію попросила саме Україна -
це у липні зробили міністри внутрішніх справ і оборони у своєму листі на адресу верховного представника ЄС
із зовнішньої та безпекової політики Жозепа Борреля.
ЄС - це не той інструмент, не та організація, яка безпосередньо опікується обороною і безпековими проблемами.
Такі місії - це маленький крок, але гарний крок, щоб нас ще більше пов'язували з ЄС як з структурою,
щоб нас розуміли і, можливо, через певний час пересвідчилися, що мають бути частиною цієї спільноти.
Швидкого рішення щодо військово-навчальної місії ЄС в Україні очікувати не варто, вважають оглядачі.
Водночас якщо його таки ухвалять, це стане важливою політичною заявою з боку ЄС.